when a girl gets all dolled up well so
the Cameron says cheese is likely she's
doing one of the most common selfie
faces back in the day most girls
resorted to the classic myspace mere
post these days a girl felt the options
are endless if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up because today we're
showing you 15 kinds of selfie faces
every girl makes one Instagram
duck face the duck face originated
during the myspace days but girls still
use this timeless pose for Instagram
selfies with their lips first their
cheekbones are on fleek this pose
started off looking sexy but now it's
more comical than anything that drinking
posed the drinking poses for girls who
want to pretend they were caught off
guard while taking a sip of their drink
but this all B's just the stage is the
rest of them - the drinking pose causes
the lipstick first in the shape of the
kids but this look is more innocent and
not as flirty
the lip cites for girls who aren't a fan
of duck face
they usually resort to the lip light for
most of their selfies by gently biting
her lower lip a girl sends out a strong
message to anyone who comes across her
picture
you know she means trouble in a good way
of course fish gate when a girl wants to
look sultry she takes cues from magazine
cover models the fish tape was made
popular by supermodels like cara
delevingne
it involves quietly opening the mouth
and showing a tiny bit of peace hiding 1
I'm the girl who wants to remain
mysterious while showing off her makeup
it's a fan of the hiding one I selfie it
has been said this post started with
makeup bloggers our Chin's would always
pose with one eye covered to show off
part of her glam on makeup
Pharaoh faced the spiral faces a flirty
make a post the highlights of girl
favorite features her gorgeous eyes are
on display when she opens them big and
wide and her lips are slightly parted
this selfie pose began in Japan and
caught on worldwide soon after kissy
face the ever so popular kissy face
clothes originated from pinup models we
use this puckered up to look in many of
their photos girls love this pose
because not only does it make their lips
look nice and plump but it also shows
off their clear cheekbone the pop pose
when a girl wants to show off her animal
side she holds up her hand like a cloth
many believe Lady Gaga who's been
spotted posing with her hand like a pot
was the creator of this cute adorable
and playful selfie pose
the toothache posed this post became
popular after magazine ads with position
models with their hands wrapped around
their cheeks to show off their nail art
this pose looks like a girl suffering
from a major toothache but it's so
pretty cute don't you think
squinch the squint is all about
squinting the eyes a bit and staring
into the camera seductively although it
makes girls look like they are blinded
by a bright light many girls Instagram
accounts are full of this type of selfie
the covered Mouse
instead of showing off their entire face
some girls prefer to do the covered
mouth selfie by fighting the lower
portion of their face but there tend
what the mouse covered all the
attraction is placed on her big
beautiful eyes mine supermodel Tyra
Banks made the slide popular on her hit
show America's Next Top Model smizing is
the art of smiling with your eyes while
your mouth stays closed in a puddle half
smile cookies sign the peace sign close
is classic it's the happy-go-lucky hand
sign that girls love it's definitely a
selfie staple
just take a look at the Instagram
profile of any girl you know the model
pout if the girl really wants to get her
crushes attention all she has to do is
the model pout about draws attention to
her lips and anyone who views her selfie
will instantly become mesmerised proud
Pugh strong face when dark and bold
Instagram brows became popular girls
wanted to find a way to show off their
accentuated eyebrows the brow to strong
posts became popular by celebrities like
Kylie Jenner put her head slightly
turned to the side and a bit of a pout
on her lips a girl's brows are the focal
point for the world to see girls tell us
the truth are you guilty of making any
of these selfie faces for your Instagram
profile so your guts in the comment
section below and don't forget to give
this video a big thumbs up